cette en commun et je t'ai mis parmi les
morts un officier mais train d'aider
l'armée rouge a probablement regarder il
a vu qu'ici je ne suis pas tout à fait
mort il m'a roulé mais parmi les morts
elle met notre qualité dans l'autre
l'hôpital de campagne militaire
soviétique et issa charlet pour l'euro
cela dit
[Musique]
on nous a mis comme qui donne raison et
on nous a dit tant danser dans un ghetto
où quelques cinq maisons
peut-être tout résultat notre style une
partie des sommes des juifs étaient
envoyés tout de suite par art suisse
dans des camps où ils étaient engagés et
à sa fille et parlait d'âge des
candidats nous ont envoyé en allemagne
o'shea nous étions au chili
aucun des six n'est d'être assassiné
mais par le travail
[Musique]
c'était de passer dans les compensations
des deux camps font sans consultation
différent car les concentrations où
j'étais à grosses roses et le luxembourg
les paysages autour cet instrument du
très très très beau et la beauté je
détestais la beauté vers la fin de la
guerre ma part la deuxième marche de la
mort je suis animé interrégimes
[Musique]
j'espère de percevoir son nom pouvoir le
co aurait dû les prochains fichiers et
énergie est extrêmement mal à l'armée
des armes armée rouge qui est pas
seulement
kia qui a combattu et avec de grands
sacrifices des d'armes et nagy néophytes
qui il climat qui grâce à eux d une
fusion
je suis dit je suis vivant
[Musique]